[Arabic recitation]
in the chapter of patience
then mentions to us a narration on the
authority of
in this narration Abu Hurra tells us
that the messenger of Allah sallaiam
said whomever Allah desires good for
he will afflict he will afflict. This
has been collected by alkari
in his authentic compilation.
This narration
has been narrated
and its meaning twofold.
Neither of the two meanings
contradict each other.
Rather both meanings when brought
together
highlight the plan that Allah subhanahu
wa tala has for his believing slave.
It's important for us before
diving into the meaning of this
narration directly
that the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
tells us
He says people
are
in their nature and in their souls like
precious metals
gold and silver.
What does this mean?
This means that gold
in its essence
has a particular look to it. There are
particular things that I can that a a
skilled jeweler can bring out of gold
that cannot be brought out of silver no
matter what.
Likewise,
there is a particular
allure. There is a particular essence to
silver that a skilled jeweler can bring
out of it that not even gold can imitate
this. There is a reason we would say
which is which is better gold or silver?
Well, most people would tell you gold of
course. It's why it's more expensive.
It's considered more precious. Sure.
But does that mean that all go all
silver should be gold then? No.
If all silver were gold, we'd have no
silver.
And just because something in its
essence, the cloth it's cut from, the
precious metal it comes from, just
because it may not be as high level as
gold, doesn't mean that everything made
out of gold is better than everything
made out of silver. Notice
this concept here.
We say which which is is better or
superior? Which is more precious of a
metal gold or silver? Say well gold.
Okay. But does that mean that every
piece of jewelry
made out of gold is better than every
piece of jewelry made out of silver? The
answer is no.
There are pieces of silver jewelry that
are far superior to
other pieces of jewelry that are made
even out of gold.
So when we speak about
generally
generally speaking gold is better than
silver but not every piece of gold is
better than every piece of silver. This
is what is known amongst the scholars as
right this wasl's argument if you
remember his argument was
I am better than him you created me from
fire
let's say for argument's sake that fire
is superior ier than dirt or mud for
argument's sake. Does that mean that
every creature made of fire is better
than every single creature made out of
mud? The answer is no. That is what the
cast systems of the Hindus and the
Buddhists
believe that you come from a certain
cast. No matter what you do,
no matter how good you are, if you're
from a lower cast, you'll never be, you
can never exceed someone from a higher
cast. And someone from a higher cast, no
matter how terrible a person they are,
they will never be
lower than a person of a lower cast.
This is
in itself either racism or tribalism
or whatever we call it. When we look at
the narrations of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam we see that for
instance who is superior in virtue the
muajir or thesar?
Their
the muajire
are superior to the
that is something agreed upon amongst
the scholars of Islam. But does that
mean that every single muhaji
is better than every individuals
doesn't mean that there may be
individuals individuals from the ansar
who are superior to individuals from the
muhajin individuals from
individuals
even
that are from the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's family members
is not a family member of the prophet
sallall.aii Wasallam.
Yet he is more virtuous than all other
companions. Hands down.
This
idea of the the cloth that a person
is cut from or the metal that they come
from.
It may be superior or inferior. It may
be virtuous or more virtuous. However,
individuals
when it comes to individuals,
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam said,
"Work and do your best for Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has made the path of
each person easy to that which he was
created for."
tell you if we understand this what does
this have to do with the narration a
person may say
when we look at a narration this
whomever Allah desires good for
he will afflict
more specifically whomever Allah God
desires good for, he will afflict and
specifically afflict with the harm of
other people. This is what the two
wordings mean.
for
[Silence]
So the narration now means whomever
Allah desires good for he will afflict
and especially with the harm of other
human beings.
This is the path of the prophets and
messengers.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has mentioned
that for every prophet he has designated
an enemy.
Every prophet gets an enemy, but not
every prophet necessarily gets a friend
or a follower because an enemy is
arguably more critical to his journey
and to his da than a friend is.
Now, what does all of this mean? And
what does that have to do with the first
half of what we're speaking of with
regards to the precious metals?
When we say why does Allah
test the human being? Why does Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tribulate people?
Why tribulation? Why hardship? Why
tears? Why isn't it all smiles?
Why isn't it that if a person worships
Allah, they are rewarded with ease in
this life and the next? And if the
person does not worship Allah, they are
afflicted with hardship. That's how you
would expect it to be. Why isn't that
the case? Wouldn't that bring about the
desired outcome which was for more
people to enter into Islam?
This here is a type of compulsion.
And this is not what we were created
for. this type of worship, a worship of
compulsion. We were created and our edge
of worship even though our worship is
very little, especially compared to the
angels, what is special about our
worship is that without compulsion, we
choose
in spite of the seduction of evil to be
good. That is why we are so
rewarded by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
It's a different kind of worship. And so
when you look at that from that
perspective,
you will notice just a jeweler
harvest
you bring to the jeweler raw materials.
Here is raw gold that has been mined.
Here is raw silver that has been mined.
The jeweler may pay the miner more for
the gold per gram than he pays him for
the silver per gram. However,
if the jeweler sees that this silver is
high quality in its vein,
he will give it his attention more than
he gives to the gold even.
And when you get when the precious metal
gets attention
from the jeweler, what does that
translate to? The jeweler is trying to
make something amazing out of this
thing. And so, is that process easy? No.
The first thing he does is heat up an
oven as hot as it can get and put this
precious metal into the belly of this
oven.
This is the first thing he does. And if
a person were to ask him, why are you
treating the silver this? Why are
you treating this precious metal like
this? He will say, because I love this
one.
This has great potential.
So who gets
the attention of the jeweler?
The one who has more potential.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us
those who are most tried and given
hardship are the prophets and messengers
and then those who are most similar to
them and then those who are most similar
to them. Just a jeweler gives more
attention
to the metal, the precious metal that he
knows to have more
potential.
We will pick this up inshallah
[Arabic recitation]